dedicamos nuestra revista de prensa a
dos temas revelados o por la prensa
estadounidense de los que se ha hecho
eco la prensa rusa el primer tema es un
artículo del Washington post titulado
Estados Unidos advierte a Ucrania que
está en un momento crucial en la guerra
pero para hablar del tema está mi
compañera Rosa Pérez más de Rosa Buen
día para usted Buen día Ángela
comenzamos Entonces no exactamente con
este artículo que mencionabas del
Washington post firmado por Yasmín
abutalip y John Hudson que empieza de la
siguiente manera a medida que se acerca
el primer aniversario de la invasión
rusa de Ucrania los funcionarios
estadounidenses dicen a los líderes
ucranianos que enfrentan un momento
crítico para cambiar el curso de la
guerra y aumentan así la presión sobre
kiev para lograr avances significativos
sobre el campo de batalla mientras fluye
la ayuda de Estados Unidos y sus aliados
bien este artículo cuenta con las
fuentes de la Administración
estadounidense de la Casa Blanca del
ejército que comentan al Washington post
que si bien las promesas de Unidos
respaldará Ucrania mientras sea
necesario probablemente permanecerán en
el tiempo es muy posible que no sea en
las cantidades en las que estamos viendo
estos paquetes de ayuda en la actualidad
no Y sobre todo con una cámara de
representantes de mayoría republicana
bien una fuente anónima la casa blanca
de la Casa Blanca cita al Washington
post Seguiremos tratando de inculcarles
a los ucranianos que no podemos seguir
así para siempre y un poco el objetivo
no de los funcionarios que visitaron
Ucrania en las últimas semanas como
asesor de seguridad nacional Wendy
Sherman subsecretaria de estado colincal
subsecretario de defensa William barts
director de la Cia fue trasladar a kiev
la naturaleza crítica de los próximos
meses de conflicto ahora en estas
discrepancias sobre Cómo enfrentar Esta
contraofensiva es en lo que se centra el
medio ruso agents media a la hora de
abordar el tema Exactamente no
precisamente está esa discrepancias y
este punto crítico al que hacíamos
referencia llega ahora porque tal y como
menciona el Washington post del artículo
Queens media replica la guerra en los
últimos meses ha entrado en una especie
de fase lenta no de rutina que no ha
habido avances considerables ni por
parte de Rusia ni por parte de Ucrania
sin embargo los analistas esperan una
gran ofensiva rusa en la primavera y
como respuesta una gran contraofensiva
ucraniana no que utilice este nuevo
armamento prometido por sus aliados
occidentales por la votan sin embargo
dicen la otan tiene temores y muchas
tensiones subyacentes de cómo debería
Ucrania enfocar estos recursos y aquí
precisamente este titular al que hacías
referencia no que Washington y kiev
discrepan sobre backmud crimea y las
perspectivas de la guerra en Ucrania y
es que analistas militares de Estados
Unidos señalan que Ucrania no puede
al mismo momento defendiendo
que prepara esta contraofensiva de Cara
a la primavera no particularmente un
funcionario estadounidense señala si
Rusia toma bacmut no resultará En ningún
cambio en el campo de batalla los rusos
lo intentarán reclamar como tal pero es
un punto como otro en el mapa por el que
han gastado una cantidad extraordinaria
de sangre y de dinero no otro punto
clave y de discrepancias no entre
Washington y kiere sería crimea Y es que
recordemos que tantos de lensky como
distintos funcionarios ucranianos han
señalado su voluntad de recuperar crimea
que fue recordemos anexionada
unilateralmente por Rusia ya en 2014
esto según las fuentes de este artículo
del Washington post se considera fuera
del alcance de las capacidades del
ejército de Ucrania y precisamente
señalando discrepancia entre los
objetivos y las posibilidades de Ucrania
es lo que hace temer a sus aliados que
esta guerra finalmente sea difícil
terminar no para finalizar con este tema
El Washington post señala Estados Unidos
quieren dar a Ucrania la oportunidad de
recuperar tanto territorio como sea
posible en los próximos meses y que
luego se siente con Vladimir Putin en la
mesa de negociación los más optimistas
esperan que Ucrania recupere territorio
en el sur frene la avanzada en el este y
que haya un acuerdo de paz para final de
este año Ángela de final de 2023
mientras a los más pesimistas señalan
que el tiempo estaría del lado de Putin
y lo que ya sabemos es que queda
implícito que Ucrania tendría Sí o sí
que perder territorio no y bueno hacer
estas renuncias que usted nos menciona
como crimea ahora justamente la guerra
en Ucrania es el punto central de la
reunión de la otan y que se realiza el
día de hoy en Bruselas bloomberg ha
tenido acceso a un borrador de las
reuniones y nos avanza algunos de los
objetivos a mediano plazo de la
organización efectivamente con un texto
firmado por Natalia Dross vamos a
señalar los tres puntos principales y en
primer lugar y es que los países de la
otan según la periodista pueden acordar
Tan pronto como este verano gastar al
menos el 2% de su pib en defensa y este
al menos sería la palabra clave no
Porque tal y como señala Henry brows
consejero Alemán de relaciones
exteriores
sistóltenberchens que el secretario
general de la otan logra que todos estén
de acuerdo en que el 2% Debería ser el
mínimo esto ya sería un proceso
significativo en realidad se esperaría
que cada estado pague más del 2% y esto
En un momento de aumento de los precios
de los alimentos y de la energía pero
sobre todo lo que destaca también la
prensa rusa es que según este educo
documento la otan se estaría preparando
para un potencial conflicto militar
desatado o bien por el artículo 5 del
tratado del tratado transatlántico el
que señala el que obliga a los miembros
de la otan a la defensa común o bien por
un conflicto fuera De esta zona de
responsabilidad En todo caso este
discurso no de aumento del belicismo no
sabemos si pues tiene una finalidad
Angela si es una cuestión disuasoria
preparatoria de retórica o dónde va a
llevar toda esta escalada finalmente
bien y sobre ese mismo discurso vamos a
conversar con nuestro siguiente invitado
del día así que gracias a usted Rosa